good after everybody welcome back from
lunch we have our third panel in this
conference on dealing with the past in
east-central europe and in fact that's
what the topic of this panel happens to
be it's an all polish panel and my
colleagues and friends starting from my
immediate left our professor Pavel
markowicz from touro university in
Poland rafa club yet ski from the
University of whoosh paavam except each
is a historian who used to work for the
institute for national memory and is now
teaching in total and the author of a
book that just came out on Radio Free
Europe mr. Stowe be at ski doctors to be
at ski is one of the leading
historiography in Poland and last but
not least my good friend madacorp nut
who works for the Institute of history
of the polish academy of sciences in
warsaw and also teaches at the higher
School of Business in navasota and who
is the author of numerous books one of
which is being printed even as we speak
so why don't we begin with Professor
maxims you very much we are supposed to
discuss the politics of history which
was already mentioned this morning first
I would like to analyze very briefly the
origins and the meaning of this notion
the politics of history in Poland this
notion was constructed was it invented
by conservative intellectuals close to
the Law and Justice Party more or less
in 2003-2004 when this party was in the
opposition again excuse me my name's
will be given very soon of course the
names of the documents and the main
goals and definitions of politics of
history were explained in this book the
book permission of page amish
remembrance and responsibility one of
the offers is here it will be a first
name is just off kloster demski
and another offer was kashima sneha we
as dogs Kiku very soon would become the
minister of culture and national
heritage after raw and justice victory
in 90 in 2005 and we as those who will
become one of the main promoters of
politics of history so what was the main
argument outlined in this book and in
many press publications by those people
who who constructed this idea first of
all that the Polish state should play a
more active role in commemorating the
national past in building current Civic
and patriotic values on the basis of
tradition on those elements of a Polish
historical past which should be regarded
as a source of inspiration for present
generations such traditions as well as a
legacy of anti-communist opposition of
Polish heroism heroism and multi-role
object from the Second World War publish
uprisings in the 19th century the
tradition of just read post paleta oh
boy Colorado so the Polish state in the
early modern and modern centuries
especially in the fifteenth sixteenth
and seventeenth century with with the
state with its democratic institutions
multinational character and religious
tolerance a politics of history as a
political and ideological project was
based on two very critical assessments
of developments in Poland after 1989 the
first assessment was with so-called
surcharge post positive effort Republic
so the state which was created in 89
after the collapse of communism Poland
but this church was paleta mingled
neglected history did not use that nas
exploits tradition national tradition to
build the moral and emotional
identification of poles we were newly
regained independent and democratic
state as a symbolic example of this
attitude was presented a slogan
from Aleksander Kwasniewski presidential
campaign in 1995 let's choose the future
so let's forget about about the past but
not only post-communist were blamed for
neglecting history and tradition the
same was said about solidarity liberal
elites dominant in the Polish politics
in the early 90s who were accused of
having a political deal with post
compost communists one of its results
was supposed to be marginalization of
history especially with respect to the
Communists crimes on one hand and and
the heroic story of anti-communist
opposition on the other hand vol so
dirty elites were also accused of having
been interested predominantly in
building liberal political and economic
institutions and at the same time having
been strongly concerned about the
possibility of awaking of Polish demons
of nationalism and xenophobia which
would could jeopardize the political and
economic progress that is why they did
their best to keep history and tradition
out of the mainstream of a public sphere
sir said those who supported the new
idea of this politics of history the
second people important assumption of
the politics of history was that if
history and tradition even played in
some respects an important role after
1989 it was not the history of pride but
rather a history of shame politicians
historians and mass media were blamed
for focusing mostly on those parts of
Polish history which were not heroic not
glorious but rather shameful shameful
like polish anti-semitic spansion of
Germans from Poland after 1945
expansions of Ukrainians flow from south
eastern Poland in 90
47 so-called activists this one is Tula
operation in this respect one may say
that politics of history was very a
reaction to vietnam nadie bait which
started in poland in the year 2000 and
for a long time dominated the public
discussions in our country this debate
was started by the publication of
lame-o's book been able neighbors by
leon thomas gross who analyzed the
massacre massacre of a Jewish
inhabitants of a small town yet verbally
committed by the Polish neighbors in
1941 in a way i would say that politics
of history was also as a special
political ideological project was also
very action to value tivities of erica
Steinberg and the German Congress of X
police who in 2003 more or less started
a new campaign in which they reminded
the expansion's accused poles of
committee committing crimes against
Germans after the war and demanded the
commemoration of the German sufferings
in the 40s so according to the promoters
of the politics of history there was a
danger that poles should be now treated
Morris perpetrators then the victims
conservative intellectuals declared that
polls now needed more pride when shame
in delinquent in the lignin with history
that they needed so-called affirmative
patriotism instead of critical
patriotism a very important chapter of
this book was written by values Gavin
who criticized young Yusuf Lipsky one of
the icons of the Polish democratic
opposition for his famous essay to
fatherland's to patriotism to patriotism
published in nineteen eighty one in this
essay Lipsky suggested that polls should
start to discuss less heroic elements of
our history harms inflict
by polls on their neighbors Jews
Ukrainians Germans for Dario's govern
this intellectual and moral attitude was
partly responsible for this patria tease
of shame which allegedly dominated the
Polish national and historical
conscience after 89 low and Justice
Party and many conservative
intellectuals declared that the time now
has come to promote with affirmative
patriotism politics of history became
one of the pillars of a political
program of the law and justice partly
which won the election in 2005 even
before word let cut risk as the mire of
war so created the museum of warsaw
uprising which was a major
accomplishment and in my opinion the
most important one so far of a whole
politics of history and this museum
obviously a concentrated on polish
heroism and sufferings before I turn to
an analysis of the politics of history
during in practice during the two years
of Law and Justice in power let me
comment on these on this theoretical
ideological basis of power politics of
history as it was formulated before 2005
in my opinion two major assessments of
politics of history as a Swiss political
and ideological project with respect to
the situation after 89 were farfetch it
or even to some extent Aaron Aaron was
false simply first the notion of
politics of history was of course not
used before early before 2003 let's say
but it was simply not true it was not
correct with the Polish democratic state
after 89 was passive and indifferent
visa V history after 89 the names of the
streets and squares were changed heroes
of a Polish anti-communist opposition
and victims of
communist and Soviet repressions where
how North communist monuments were put
down and the new monuments were erected
I mentioned in the in the morning the
monument devoted to the victims of
Soviet repression during the war another
example could be a monument of the
polish home army in front of the Polish
Parliament school curricula and
textbooks were changed functionaries of
the security apparatus from the 40s and
the 50s so from this most brutal time of
Stalinist were deprived of special
privileges that were enjoyed by by
veterans in Poland as I said yesterday
illustration law was passed in 1997 and
below about the institute of national
remembrance was passed in nineteen
ninety eight this law was vetoed by the
president fresh nevsky but this veto was
rejected by by the parliament again and
in the year 2000 the institute of
national remembrance started to function
and in my opinion this moment was very
real turning point in terms of politics
of history although again without using
this is no notion institute of national
remembrance was a very large institution
with many local branches dealing with
the whole Polish history after the
outbreak of the Second World War so
altogether a period of the Second World
War and the whole period of a communist
dictatorship institute of national
remembers remembrance carried out many
initiatives in terms of Education
Research commemoration and also
prosecution of the Communist crimes one
can of course L view that argue that
always a forced especially before
founding convey institute of national
remembrance were not persistent enough
one can be critical of specific
developments or decisions in this realm
but it was only a political and
propaganda slogan to say that before law
and justice came to power Paulo state
was absolutely passive and in
different visa vie history the science
second me miscalculation or at least a
great exaggeration was saying that same
and this critical but really dominated
polish discussions about history in the
90s and in the air that the first years
of this new century it is worth
mentioning that no public opinion
surveys were ever presented to support
this opinion that on the mass scale this
critical patriotism really became
dominant rubber very vers the only large
public opinion survey was carried out in
2003 by pant or the Polish title was
power transfer but just watch TV polish
society and its past and this survey the
survey demonstrated that polls still
remembered mostly heroic and glorious
elements of the history people mentioned
mostly heroism in the Second World War
Corey Soviet war in 1920 the war which
was won by by the poles and the
regaining of any of the independence in
nineteen 818 these were balls historical
events but polls mentioned most
frequently only three percent of the
respondents said that they felt shame
because of the negative attitudes of
post word towards Jews during the second
patrol it was it was after this internal
debate so by any means it does not
support their feces but the thesis which
was very important for the origins of a
political of history that involvement
debate and other historical discussions
after 89 reshaped the Polish historical
conscious consciousness making shame the
central part of it for many polls in
including myself yet but not debate was
a great accomplishment of the Polish
state
including politicians historians and the
public opinion we managed to reveal a
horrible truth with dignity and accuracy
and I think that it did not jeopardize
the Polish standing abroad rather the
contrary i would say that polish jewish
relations before much better became much
better after very hit public debate then
they were before verdad meant debate the
Polish openness was widely appreciated
and I would also say that that this
environment debate did not change the
traditional model of the Polish
patriotism this debate rather
demonstrated that we were a mature and
self-confident nation was able to come
forth confront its whole past not only
heroic elements and now a few words
about politics of history as it was
implemented after law and justice
victoria in 2005 so during these last
two years in terms of new institutions
the museum museum of a Polish history
was established by Minister of Culture a
kashmiri ostrovsky in a few years it
should become a sophisticated and modern
museum but for the time being the museum
exhibition does not exist yet and the
museum team carries out many educational
initiative exactly the same type of work
which had been done by the institute of
national remembrance since 2002 but I
would say that the institute of national
remembrance carried out similar
activities but on a larger scale it was
simply a much bigger nationwide
institution before many local branches
so suddenly the establishment of a
museum of a Polish history for me was
not a turning point point in any sense
another important and positive feature
of the politics of history for me was
the role of President locket rinsky who
patronized many historical
commemorations like for example the
commemoration of drum 1956 surprising
the commemoration of
90-79 t 76 workers revolt president
kaczynski also rewarded with state
decorations hundreds of veterans of
anti-communist opposition many of them
had been so far neglected or it is not
enough appreciated however I see also
many negative developments which
influence politics of history and drop
our diced it's very mink and its goals
first was wet the main public
institutions which were involved in the
politics of history both new
institutions created by law and justice
like a museum of a Polish history and
Museum of Warsaw Uprising when locket
risky was when my mayor of justice and
also these institutions which existed
for a longer time but i would say that
all this is still institution on our
most August into social institution
during last two years were dominated by
the people close very close to law and
justice party in terms of politics in
terms of ideological values I think that
the same could be said also about the
public TV which produced many historical
documentary programs the result of this
predominance of one political and
ideological option was i would say
one-sided vision of history this vision
has emphasized importance of selected
currents of anti-communist opposition
like like armed resistance from
authorities like like importance of the
catholic church as an anti-communist
force as radical antico anti-communist
groups in the Solidarity movement in the
in the 80s especially such a group
called sorry Darnell Valjean job
solidarity where the militant but it's
fighting solidarity on the other hand
this
down plate or even rejected very
importance of other softer let's say and
more moderate opposition groups
especially over liberal and left-wing
background this vision of history
presented the roundtable discussions as
a deal with the Communists or even in
more extreme versions as a treason most
most developments in the so-called such
as it was pointed third republic after
89 were presented as controlled by the
communists and a special kind of
conspiracy awkward this word is very
hard to translate to English conspiracy
arrangement network perhaps awkward in
Polish Paul according to this vision my
polish democratic institutions and this
independent state after 89 were at least
partially fake the whole period after 89
was often presented rather as a failure
when as a success what was really
missing in politics of history during
last two years was pluralism if politics
of history is supposed to be widely
accepted it should include a wide
variety of opinions existing in the
social and cultural reality instead of
imposing the views of only one part of
political and ideological spectrum the
second and even more important feature
of politics of history by law and just
it was in my opinion manipulation of
history for the purposes of current
political struggle one can quote many
speeches and interviews by Prime
Minister's of kuklinski who used history
to stigmatize his political opponents
according to Katrina skill of injustice
continued the best and most sacred
tradition of the Polish patriotism and
especially over home army tradition is
most important anti-german and
when Soviet organization resistance
movement during the Second World War
while the opponents of Law and Justice
like for example gazeta the Balch and
many other people of liberal of our
left-wing background were presented by
Katrina ski as successors of the
tradition of a communist party of Poland
who are responsible for the horrors of
study knees in Poland according to this
specific interpretation of a Polish
history Adam ethnic editor-in-chief of
desert of abortar so with mine anti Law
and Justice newspaper other mechanic
spent several years in the Communist
prisons not for the sake of a free and
democratic Poland but supporting one of
the supporting one of the communist
party factions against another one
during the party meeting in recognised
shipyard Medina shipyard where nesoid
are it was born a Kachina ski identified
low and just above this great tradition
of solidarity and the opponents of the
law and justice with Zama this is an
polish abbreviation of anti-riot
communist police who attacked solidarity
followers during the Marshall ozawa
Osama was the most hated abbreviation in
in Poland in the 80s and it for everyone
who remembers that time it exactly
evokes very bad memories out of all
together in my opinion politics of
history instead of building the sense of
national pride and community as it was
supposed to to do this politics of
history in practice during last two
years was very often used to exclude
political opponents from this national
community this politics of history in my
opinion became a part of a very
aggressive style of law and justice
politics stimulating conflicts with many
political and
social groups one can argue that it did
not influence the real politics of
history as a as with ideological project
but it was only party politics but
always uses dirty tricks and slow
dancing in every country in the
Democratic state but I cannot accept
such explanation conservative
intellectuals who created this notion of
politics of history demanded that the
public sphere should be full of
historical references that political
leaders should not turn our backs on
history like Alexander Nevsky who
ostensibly trolls future instead of
history and tradition so in last two
years we could see how history was used
by politicians and for me it was
politics in history in practice and it
was also not a very optimal optimistic
lesson for me at least risking a certain
simplification we can look at the
phenomena politics of history from three
different perspectives I think the first
is connected with the term politics of
history married and my colleague
mentioned and analyzes this desperate
problem and the function it should be
performed I think that we we can
distinguish three functions of politics
of history let legitimizing or
ideological the second integrative
activist and the deferred uncovering
function
with the end of showing strange false
contents and defining the enemy enemies
both in internal and foreign affairs the
second purpose the perspective deal with
an attempt to reconstruct the most
important issue and arguments using by
supporters and opponents of politics of
history and I think that the most
important problem is the concept of
tomorrow patriotism let's say or new
version of of polish by patriotic and
finally the fact that the fact
perspective concentrate on the question
what this debate is saying about us
historians Pavel Merrigan and and me
about asked historians past
participating in it in this debate and I
would like in my presentation to focus
on the problem historians facing
politics of Earth history
the 19th century left us I think two
images of historians which still
predominate in research circles the
first one is related to to the figure of
the neutral observer the impartial
searcher for truth who is guided only by
cognitive / sweet I think that the
symbol of this historian the most famous
was local from drunken the second
identifies the historian as the
spiritual guide and the educator of the
nation who would like to transform
history into a treasure of useful
knowledge and an important part of
common opinion we may get the impression
that in the debate on politics of
history both images are somehow being
updated and gaining new justification
obviously the supporters of politics of
history most often identified themselves
with the latter image the key issue is
in this context remains the relationship
between historiography and social life
especially politics as usual the
starting point is that diagnosis of
everything that happened in Poland after
1989 according to one side of the debate
the characteristic feature of this
period was that historians believe that
the role of the researcher could replace
that of the judge and see the citizen
and politicians occupied themselves with
politics of history choosing a future
without any reference to the past in the
opinion of the supporters of politics of
memory the division between the
scientific and the public sphere is
inherently false and artificial and
cannot be sustained
one characteristic statement of this
point of view goals quotation I cannot
completely understand how a historian
can declare that in reality he does not
belong to the political sphere it is not
only the question of the contrast
between the historian and the politician
who comes from outside and is demanding
of or suggesting something or wants to
use his knowledge instrumentally
politics in its broad sense is present
in the historians very activity in such
elementary issue as choosing a subject
for research and presentation I think
that politics does not exist somewhere
else it is an inherent part of all human
activity and therefore of the activities
of the historian his decisions is the
conclusion our political / excellence
and should be treated as such from this
perspective when they add that the
results of historical research are not
used only for scientific purposes but
should also contain some educational
aspect supporters of politics of history
want to legitimize two types of
historical discourse in regard to their
social role the academic and the popular
scientific according to them historical
research is a mission that is clearly
described by one researcher as follows
rotation history implies some obligation
we cannot revive the imagination of
young generation only with souvenirs we
must show them certain tasks for history
if they want to feel the value of being
polished opposing this we find the
voices of those representatives of
historic
circles who favored the first of the
above-mentioned images of the historic
they are afraid of involving the
historian in current politics for
presenting his political views and ideas
clearly contradicts the idea of
independent historiography here is one
example the sphere of the past should
remain the alternance domain of
researchers and should not be given away
to the prosecutors who roll memory
according to the interest of the state
or resin dead other researchers know
that there are two ways of dealing with
history gratitude is and mercenary in
the former case even the worst true is
better than a lie in the latter the
researchers favors the selective and
instrumental aspects of science there
are some radical opinions among the
opponents of the politics of history the
description political historian
sometimes becomes the personification of
someone who knows what he knows and does
not bother to prove it and moreover
insult others it is an image with
contradicts the ideal of the historian
works to pursuit of truth and this
regards the common rules of historical
methodology the moderate value the more
moderate voices of the seeking a
compromise between the world of politics
and the historical community are in a
model are in a minority my neighbor
parvo MacTavish voice a similar idea in
his opinion both sides should be long
cited and deliberate politicians must
appreciate the significance of history
support scientific research and
educational activities relating to the
past but avoid
and instrumental approach but historians
that my father matzav it should
recognize their civic obligations and
the fact that the result of their work
are important not only for them but for
the whole community at the same time
they should guard their independence as
they would protect their own eyes avoid
the temptation of court historiography
and be able to say no to the politician
in certain situation and the conclusion
I believe that such a model of
cooperation is achievable however
difficult it would simplify the picture
if one fault that this layer of the
discussion about politics of history
revealed only a fundamental conflict
between two image of historian the
independent scientist and the historian
concerned about the spirit of the
community it is also an issue of the
place of knowledge about the past in
public debate and the question about the
historians responsibility consequently
the following questions become
significant first should the researcher
remain indifferent towards different
model ways of using the past second it
is possible to limit the above-mentioned
problem of responsibility only remaining
faithful to truth in the most reasonable
meaning of this web and historical
methodology or should it reach beyond
the purely scientific sphere and
emphasize the historians obligation
towards the community state national or
local the voices of historians presented
above with the emphasis on differences
rather than on similar with similarities
with regard to the debate on politics of
history
allow us to come to what are obviously
provisional conclusions first there can
be no doubt that this debate on politics
of history which has gone on several
years has not only brought new life into
scientific circles but has also helped
us all to realize that the past
measurement in the present exercise
extraordinary power and constitute an
interesting component of our culture
secondly the debate has revealed
although so far only hazley the
controversy surrounding the relationship
between historiography and collective
memory the reason for this situation is
an almost similar life simul Thomas
change in the circumstances under which
professional historians operate as
wojcik josek my colleague from Poznan
observed in a slightly different context
historians breath in the stereotypes of
their profession and recognize the fact
of briefing only when the circumstances
in which they breath change the
identification of history with memory
has I think two consequences one is the
rapid intensification of use of the
passing politics tourism and the economy
the other is the fact that the historian
and the most important for me has lost
his traditional monopoly over the
interpretation of the past today the
historian is not only broad user of the
past he shared this role with judges
witnesses the media and legislators and
thirdly the debate raised the question
of which model of politics of history
Poland should adopt especially in
relation to our neighbors undoubtedly
ever politics of history relates to a
certain system of values therefore it is
worth wondering whether it should be a
civic party based on the notion of human
rights democracy and pluralism or a
national parody emphasizing the
following issues sober in the dangerous
of the nation and the national stay
there are two reasons why it is hard to
answer this question in Poland on the
one hand Poland is in a difficult
geopolitical position and nothing will
change even we assume that it would be
easier to achieve a compromise with the
Germans using the civic or multinational
code we still have to deal with the
challenge of Russian politics of history
celebration of the 60th anniversary of
the end of the Second World War and the
at the last at the last articles on
Russian newspapers shows that we are
facing a revival of national and
imperialism rhetoric on the other hand
we must face the dilemma on which
axiology should we base the program of
politics of history are we mentally
prepared to use to system of values
simultaneously it is a possible at all
its consequences would involve
compromise between the contradictory
ecologies priorities and methods use in
different cases the debate about
politics of history has already raised
many such question I think only by
answering them can we move
beyond well now comfortable ways of
thinking and undirected at a civic
aspect to history does project
protecting Polish people from the always
dangerous act of you serving it thank
you were mental Minh I my communication
is consecrated to the question of
history they treated as a factor of
international relations and i would like
to start with the question about the
policy of history politics of history as
a factor we would benefit or not to to
the group to polish foreign policy the
firm the term politics of history
referred to serve often in the recent
times is one of those terms that
inspires heated debates such a debate
has been present in poland for some time
now and it circulates primarily around
the very legitimacy of the term yet this
depart from the essence of what i would
like to concentrate on for the term
itself is the is of lesser importance
than the meaning awaited carries or the
content that it is inscribed into it
quite naturally one needs to be above of
the fact that the term politics of
history was not created in poland rather
it has been introduced in power
parlons through the German language with
what is described by the German World
gosh it's politic a term that come to be
used in Germany longley earlier once
again the term itself is of lesser
importance the very phenomenon which it
describes it okie significance politics
of history constitutes a phenomenon that
is not a new one and historian of Polish
historiography must readily admit that
in Poland in the interwar period as well
as under the communist regime the state
through various means made attempt to
shaping historical consciousness in the
interval Poland those efforts
concentrated on the dissemination of the
insurrection tradition which trimmed in
Poland returned into the map of Europe
and father with the victorious war
against the Soviet Russia in 1920 and
this historical perspective was
accompanied by a strong contempt for the
conciliatory stances with regard to the
occupying to the partitioning powers
that would have their part in shaping
the history of the post partition Poland
when Poland came to be governed by the
communist regime attempts attempts were
made at recreating a version of Poland
past that would fall in line with the
communist ideology prevailing at the
time ideology that was trust on the
Polish nation without from without the
identity of communist Poland which was
supposed by the growing
achievement of the thousand-year history
of Poland was built on their contempt
for the Second Republic questo first of
all for the interval independent Poland
from the period before the World War two
there is hardly any society that is able
to function without the very symbols the
values the imponderable yeah which are
the foundations of community of each
community those symbols may change or be
altered in the inner long-term
perspective nevertheless there
indispensability cannot be delegated in
a pluralist society also is any
democratic society in any democratic
society they need four symbols for in
tempura before imponderable yeah place a
very special role since all the
attributes that divide and distinguish
the people need to be balanced with
something that bind that binds them
together undeniably the politics of
remembrance require long-term efforts
and hardly any cultural moves it is
essential to come to understand that
prayer requisite the fact that the past
has a has an influence on the present
that history is a political science in
quotation that very fact that this fact
is not new it is a reality that simply
needs to be taken into account the ties
between history and politics constitute
permanent preconditions history is a
political science as alexis de
tocqueville clearly stated
in the unexpired value of historical
arguments in shaping international
relations was acknowledged in early 20s
by Polish historians for example by what
is not gonna bring ski one of the most
important personalities in publishes the
river he in this time in this
indisputably the variety of influences
that the past holds over the present in
the life of Nations is self-evident a
well-known French historians Francois
furai the author of Depa a very
well-known book la passage in Elysium
would write that there is nothing such
an untrained historical interpretation
the history which is written is still
embedded in history it Springs from
history it is the product of an imporant
in parliament x definition relation
between the present and the future an
assembly of the particular rights of an
individual mind with a vast ground of
its possible routes in the past I'm
finished in quoting does politics being
a matter of the present must necessarily
relate to the past in its own way
history shapes politics and politics
influence history this by no means
implies that there is no historical
truth that is that it is the politics
which define what the historical truth
may be evidently an opposite approach
exist a
in historiographical tradition our times
have witnessed the pursuit of the
perspective holding that a history that
more history means more conflicts
conflicts that tier societies apart
apart and divided nations more than once
we have seen manifestations of the
strong opposition against politicizing
history the view that history
intoxicates relations between the
nation's had been the fundament of the
world commented manifesto against
history written by Paul Valery regards
your letter activated ailment in 19 to
publish in 1932 were the author expands
on the deadly chemistry of the intellect
which is history for him let us also to
mention that Paul Kennedy famous
historian learning historian who would
write in 1972 about the decline of
politicising and nationalistic history
the experience of history politicized
ideology lized is deeply rooted in the
consciousness of Polish Society in
Polish intelligentsia and for those very
reasons a prerequisite for an earnest
politics of history to be pursued lies
in the effort to select those elements
of the past which are of particular
importance and which in fact are
constitutive for our identity and the
community today the process of selecting
tradition selecting that to which every
nation has a right but equally that
which every nation creates its own way
should not lead to oblivion
for those of history's events that have
been less vulnerable and neither should
it lead to manipulation I would like to
consider one question which is I suppose
of utmost what are the most important
and this question is the vision of
Polish state abroad and I suppose that
these problems is a very important
healed of the policy of history which
should overcome this region it would be
a mere platitude to state that the
international status of giving country
always depends on such objective
elements as the territory and population
economic potential etc all that is
beyond that yet it is equally clear that
the status of the country is shaped by
that by it's past its best understood as
a significant intuitive factor
undeniably the perceptions of a given
nation are influenced by its past and it
would be highly irrational to disregard
the very fact that formulating long-term
political course ooh considering this
issue I would like to mention on what
seems to meme the most pressing question
today one of the great challenges facing
Poland's foreign policy is the attempt
to change the perception of Polish state
and publish nation in the West every
historians who is familiar to the
history of Poland's diplomacy
over the past century must admit that
the question is very important it would
be a mistake to think that the problems
which Poland faces and to it relate to
its perception abroad are knew it would
be a great oversimplification with the
enormity of negative opinions on Poland
in the past two years to the MER prism
of unfavorable attitude toward baggage
in skis the sources of that phenomenon
reach much deeper the events of the past
two years have rather delivered reasons
and perhaps protect to reveal in the
West the all-time negative stereotypes
of Poland with new force for a historian
of diplomacy it seems appropriate here
to reach to the history of Poland of
Poland's foreign policy in the interwar
period prior to nineteen thirty-nine in
the view of the world public opinion our
country does not enjoy a sufficient
recognition of his rights and interests
which have been long forgotten for the
period of our bondage such was the world
that were the words spoken in 1926 by
Polish foreign minister August Zaleski
SAT was in essence the foreshadowing
legacy of the great of the great bondage
of the Great Library having inherited it
the Polish state must struggle with the
opposition of that part of the world
opinion unfavorable to our return into
the international arena it is striking
how accurate has that assessment proved
to be in fact those were words could
those very well could
welcome to be repeated by appublished
politician today surely the negative
stereotype of Poland abroad was the
result of the partitions a consequence
of the lack of statehood and outcome of
the situation that prevented poles from
voicing their own opinion under the
influence of the historiography
developed in the partitioning by the
partitioning powers and particularly by
Russian historiography German Russian
historiography a stereotype of Polish
honor he was born and the row type of
Poland as a state in culpable incapable
of functioning I was very very hard very
was crucial for this vision of Polish
state the depth stereotype was then
strengthen and thus is survived Poland
demonstrates constant disarray anarki
and flourishing infinitely Poland is
presently a state of electronic anarchy
was the assessment by this by historians
following the World War two the old
stereotype of Polish anarchy was only
favored by the German references
regarding Poland as a saison stat and
the argument attempted to show the
civilization grounded inferiority of
poles the inescapability of Polish
energy and economic collapse or new
Chevy truck for example for the case the
Western historiography was dominated by
the image of Poland as a state as a
state of disarray the stereotype of
Polish anarchy was a notable element of
the Black Legion of Poland in the West
the very stereotyped offered a highly
suggestive job justification for the
partitions of Poland the loss the loss
of the statehood the consequences of
which have featured so prominently in
historical writing results in Poland
ever since 18th century and with a brief
exception of the interwar period
oscillating between limited freedom and
total submission as wrote polish
historian today's web kofsky the Polish
state proved unable to defeat the
negative stereotype of Poland today it
is capable of doing just that but are
its efforts efficient it is it is the
question it is the very important
question and I suppose that by this but
these remarks I would like to to let us
to to consider this problem as one of
the most important fields of Polish
historiography of today let us make some
conclusions first of all the state I
suppose the state must play it's
important
roll important part in fulfilling the
duty of cultivating remembrance of those
part experiences within the particular
way condition our identity that is
beyond dispute it holds the obligation
to regain the ground lost under the
half-century long community domination
and the hardly independent polish
statehood thus it is not an issue of
what politics of history might mean but
rather the question of what conditions
should be met for it to be effective to
serve the interests of national
community a changing the perception of
Poland possesses the great challenge for
the Polish state and of weakening of the
negative stereotype of Poland stands as
the most fundamental goal the deeply
rooted historical stereotype naper
system and alienating their surprising
strength in shaping the perception the
perception of nations would definitely
require a distinct study for example the
voluminous monographie monograph should
be necessary in this question they are
strange in is indisputable today it
stands as a particular paradox that in
the period of revolution in
communications at a time when border
ceased to exist the nations and peoples
are drawn closer to each other the power
of stereotypes in mutual perception of
the nation's hadn't been a weakened
thank you very much
thank you gentlemen we have time for
questions and I open the floor professor
Vulcan there would you mind Elizabeth
going to the microphone please
very simple factual question of mr.
mcsavage namely how did this affirmative
patriotism favored by the law and
justice party effect textbooks and
history teaching in high schools and at
the University and to what extent was it
also affected places like the Institute
of history or was it well I save it okay
let's do yeah I'm sorry let's take a few
questions I've got another comments them
question but of course I understand that
it would be answer from a comments
because it's very difficult for me to
agree with brilliant explanation was
happening Poland have mailed by
Professor Marty rich at the beginning I
as far as know there is some
misunderstanding because if I know the
people who used this term of political
of political politics of history they
never told that this project of politics
of history which existed before but
which was a name it was politics it was
kind of pedagogy built on the fear of
the Rising polish nationalism that they
never understood that they were fully
successful now so this results of this
pause nothing change but we could
compare it with another results of the
polls if we are asking the polls how
they understanding how they estimate
they themselves would be that this very
strange
a result that the pause if we compare
with another nation of Europe they they
are they underestimate themselves
comparing with the delayed detonation
there is no there is no such a because
the people who use this pedagogy at the
beginning of 90s throwing rather
shameful side of our history had to be
afraid to to emphasize the heroic past
they they were afraid of this rising of
nationalities rising of national pride
etc but in reality that we couldn't find
such such attitude among the pause it is
rather the complexity of inferiority so
we can say that this pedagogy successful
in certain sense of course is you
mentioned that they were of course they
weren't neglecting the anniversary of
heroic events etc data but I could give
one example it was 94 in da da da da da
it was 94 that was 15 anniversary of
Warsaw Uprising it was the biggest
article which was devoted to the 11
history that is it was one criminal
groups who killed the Jews among the a
car that mean national army who killed
the Jews of course it was the most
important the biggest article about it
which provoke a lot of debate in Poland
and there is question if if there really
such a this fact was proven that was the
true but there is a question if it's
really reflected what happened to our
juice what was the attitude of the acha
toh are Jews and
you said that debate about it but
nothing changed was rather better 444
Polyjuice relation I'm not so it isn't
so evident for me because if I know I've
got such a discussion suit under the lot
of people from Israeli haven't know that
the a car defended Jews that they were
even the cellular Toto Toto Toto to
fight for the Jews that they were
condemned the people who denounced the
Jews etc but there's another problem
with advisor I'm absolutely it was the
reason to rise the public debate about
the involvement I'm i agree but look the
people who rise dis debate who said that
we dis obvious that we have to debate it
it was a dark side of our history you
have to deal with it because we have
this necessity the same people repeat
last for a long time that the what's
happened before 8989 it isn't important
the same people gathered abroad such as
Adam evening it isn't important what
happened that we are born at 89 it isn't
important what happened and this this
history mean nothing for us and looking
for the reason what's happened now in
Poland after the fall of communism in
the Communist is something
misunderstanding so it was it was also
this element of this pedagogy which was
politic of history of course because we
couldn't I think we could imagine state
without politics of history of course we
we don't need this name but how could we
imagine the stage which is responsible
of the education of the system of the
dedication of not only the state is in
some kind of a nation of the
collectivity which is in a row cheat in
the past the passage on the things which
we have we don't the
future don't belong to us so how could
you imagine this state without these
politics so if there is such a politics
we had it's better to add toto to say it
because this kind of pedagogy which was
basis on this on this reflecting shadow
this this dark side of our past and to
showing that that is but we have to be
very prudent with our history because
always these heroic events were combined
with terrible mistake not only mistake
but but the crime etc it was the kind of
pedagogy but it was with hypocracy
because it was showing as that we are
through so maybe I talking too much but
I think that as few question even for
you thank you thank you Lavinia just a
quick question are there any opinion
polls reporting on interest in
transitional justice politics of history
I and i'm not talking about necessarily
opinion polls carried in 2007 also in
the 1990s if you know and is there any
evidence for a generational gap
yeah I have a question comments and 3
points 1 point this is the situation you
both described before defaulting his new
politics of this stuff and I think we
have two dimension tool ever let's say
professional historiography and then how
how the vodka public and I'll state
react and adopt this you know on the
level of the of the of the particular of
the historiography what historian have
done that this is done I remember when
we met first time you said to me
something what was very shocking from
you there's you are this time vice
director of the institute of national
remembrance yeah as a very there's a
conscience between us as we do yesterday
pure playing skee said we should defend
it yeah we will do yeah but you said to
me at this time we are talking that in
part in Poland there's no one historian
younger generations who is dealing with
the Nazi occupation of porn you know
then I have met a younger historians got
a huge group from from the also German
Institute of history who are working and
they they were astonished you know
archive are not opened up and himself
also at many other topics we mentioned
we are talking about you mentioned in
your speech about how German historians
are dealing now with the GDR every
aspect of GD our histories every every
element of resistance is regstrate I am
afraid than in 20 years if somebody
looked you know at the Columbia
University Library and will look and see
hundred books on German resistance
against communists and two books by
marcin cooler about Sarah garnish
movement and some other yeah samatha
then then you see that there will be out
of the proper
so I would say oh even on this level
before the Institute because Institute
was of course done as a very in as a
work which we all appreciate but before
and there's the questions why why it was
so and say I wanted to refer to you what
you say of course as it is always
axiology behind as a you up as a
historian are also public intellectuals
yeah even if there are you know they
have professional method answer it was
red but sorgen to speak with with mother
it was atmos atmosphere of the time that
the mostly you know I just finished the
project about concerning Ukrainian
lately to any and so the most
interesting works done by the younger
polish historian were very critical
about polish politics you can you know
because it was it was about minority
politics and then sons of general nobody
was interested in the German occupation
because it seems to be art stuff test
why and like I go on the other level
because you know after 89 this is the
disagreement i think that they were at
least and you tried to reconstruct an 01
level in your paper this concept of the
policy of history as a part of the new
account of new political philosophy or
public philosophy now to dazzle say it's
it's emerged as a as a as a a part of
diagnose it is something wrong with
polish democracy and the question was
what what was wrong and i was convinced
and many of my colleagues were convinced
that is because they are the other
concept how the polish democracy should
didn't what what they wear and they all
were against so-called affirmative
political political history of politics
for instance pasala darkness as a
liberal posts re-diagnosed globe stream
with idea such i cannot develop a civil
society but historically
Europe Constitution not patriotic taken
from harbor mouth for instance I you
remember you know the defense discussion
with uni-t about is there any collective
memory at all fun yeah it was you know
in this ideology because you can
reconstruct this we are referring to too
many publicist my hair creamy many at
land some vodka svenska and and Soviet
ski you can see why why they thought
because it was mentioned already because
of the of the thing that the most
dangerous things for Paul's are
nationalists after 89 we the people
common is probably what is the Fiona's
as a maybe national sleep then there was
there was a liberal group if you if you
remember what the Donald Tusk one set
about the people from the guys kappa
about to be polished the polish identity
polish way in the history he said it's
abnormal yeah it's a very difficult mr.
yeah it's a up to normal because it's a
you know you beauty we are always
defeated yeah so you have it was not
yeah according to the to get to the
various of different success and the
second is a big group political group
because they are also for it correct as
well of course post comments and if you
take now what audio port is very
difficult to do this political speeches
delivered by fascist for instance to the
martial law anniversaries to sala de los
angeles's you you you you could
reconstruct actually what was the
philosophy of this day and it was not
this one because of course post comments
had not
he has now really intense Kiki of a
function as a president of all paws and
they tried to reintegrate in his
language also you know some positive
aspects of the Polish history but it was
very difficult so this is why it changed
you know it's change and once again of
course never you said something about
you know about Florence I didn't I don't
think that Perl is before especially in
the mid-nineties was greater than the
death entered then today our last two
years because I think that one of the
protocols Dominic now what you made that
later in your paper you're identified it
is a kind of public philosophy and the
kind of conception with the party
politics with the politics of the party
law and justice so it's if I think it's
a little unfair because it's we can talk
about these politics and about what what
was done in the in the last two years
but nobody of these intellectuals you
mentioned the sides of us does give us
minister of culture is involved i
letting the politics especially not in
Party politics it is not that it is I
would say it's the opposite case that
the part the law and justice try to to
use some concept which were in there in
there in there the public's here and
push it forward but to say I think they
also didn't mentioned also some positive
saying as I made during these two years
many conference is given by the Museum
of Warsaw Uprising the idea for instance
that you will organize also according to
the you know in in the case of the
former German territories that we are
not only be critical about
steinberg and print and so on but you
know to reconstruct the history of the
of the before direct after 45 of the of
the the people who move who were moved
from the from the east polish territory
to the west socotra yemen cisco many
sorry done with Valjean sir it made it
you mentioned this I think you know we
were also with blahnik in the broad
swath too common in the commemoration of
these people of Surrey tarnished by
chance I was very moved because they are
very courageous people does the word
thought they were totally neglected
there you know there are the losers yeah
they are not rich yeah they are not they
became not important politicians they
are not known in the india world yeah
update they were courageous people and i
think it was in what was the achievement
of the stool two years that this one
side is and the lack of flawless and the
lack of pleurisy memory was a little you
know remove except for it was never said
it was never said that if dis
affirmative politics of history it
should be should be a kind of you know
mythological expression and neglect of
all negative sides of of the Polish
history I myself was in the apartment
about a debate and and so but I i would
say nobody III saw always it is
exaggeration to considered false as the
most that serious perpetrators in the
history like in the book from now on I'm
Arkin and
and the and the others so it says it's
not it's not I think it's not not the
case and it is not surprising is it too
easy to say that on the end it was a
kind of you know striving for monumental
ization uncritical monumental ization of
the Polish mr. it was it is not the case
it's a it's a if we look wider also
museum of the warsaw uprising has
success because it's a it's a model yeah
its appeal to their 222222 they also
refer to the younger generation but it
is not apologetic is affirmative in this
sense that the shows the design we will
contain the indian did the first the
first philosopher the show also that
this country has something long
tradition log in the european history
and can something contribute to european
present okay we shall last question
I would like to congratulate mr. Conrad
on his great perception I think of the
root of thunder at least the ICO's
important polish sort of self image in
the world in the partitions I think
that's been totally neglected and even
as far as I know polish history there
has been really an exhausting discussion
of what were the causes of polish
partitions and I want to tell you that
from what I know this is really deeply
rooted in the world and you can see it
in the united states that actually an
important part of the day reaction to
polish partitions as part of the
political tradition in the united states
and that has to do with the idea the
Americans decided that the cause of
Polish part polish partitions were the
fact that the kinks were elected in
Poland were foreign-born and therefore
there was this great emphasis in
American Constitution and I was reading
it an American constitutional history
that no for important person can become
president of the United States and then
there's this myth of a Manchurian
Candidate which is the guy who disguises
Chris foreign origin and actually he
acts in the interest of the point power
while he's carrying Isis and this is
true in popular culture and in the sort
of in American history so I think that
this is definitely an area that should
be you know discussed further and maybe
again looking from the poly off of
polish point of view what were the
causes of partitions in Poland and
whether it was truly disarray or they
were other things but this this is I can
you ever write that this still exists in
foreign perceptions of Poland thank you
the first question concerned the problem
of textbooks above on the university
level and at schools as far as very
university libraries concerned
universities are absolutely autonomous
and the government did not have any
tools to influence whether the textbooks
I don't want to say that the government
government wanted to influence with
textbooks at universities but it would
it would be impossible in fact the
situation is different it'd be different
as far as schools are concerned this is
Minister of Education which accepts
which chooses the textbooks but they're
all is that usually for each level of
education were more or less 10 to 20
various textbooks but each of them has
to be approved by the Minister of
Education and teachers can in each
school choose whatever book very
regardless as the best and the problem
with the Ministry of Education is that
the minister of education was a very
extreme politician and Roman geared even
not from the law and justice party but
from the League of Polish families and
Roman Gertie tried to influence the
textbooks quite recently the Polish
press published information that
Minister of Education tried to reject to
text books because a review a reviewer
wrote that one textbook
included too much about polish
anti-semitism and another textbook
mentioned the invasion of a Polish army
of the origin in slovakia in 38 what
will be varying this word for the
audience all the salsa so I think but in
case of ministry of education and
textbooks this process somehow has been
initiated but this was only the very
beginning now a range of vince time
microphone the whole process of the
acceptance of the the textbook at the
Ministry of Education takes like between
18 and months and two years which means
that even if your attic was that skilful
to you know to find reviewers who would
stop and pleasant textbooks well it's
not in the ministry anymore 44 sometimes
this is a good news and this is this is
nothing new at all so okay even if there
were attempts like this that they were
just you know fruitless because of these
you know bureaucratic machinery and two
years is just just detail about the the
old government in power so but mrs. this
is exactly what wha what I said that it
was just the beginning and if one gear
take stating in office longer I would
imagine that this process could be
completed perhaps I said that this
hatchet process was just initiated and
it was only the very beginning and now
brains were fixed I mentioned with
article by mijo chica in 1994 about what
surprising and about whether soldiers of
a home army who murdered seduce and I
agree well but it was a one of the most
extreme examples of this let's say
critical approach to a Polish history
and I think that he was criticized
afterwards even by many of his
colleagues from gazeta wyborcza I but I
would also save and gazeta wyborcza I
part from this article by Amy ho Chi he
published hundreds of articles about
polish history polish opposition
anti-communist resistance the problem
gazeta wyborcza was not that it
neglected history but that other mythic
imposed his own
views regarding whether agreement
between solidarity and and tend to
communists and regarding any possible
kind of coming to terms with legacy of
dictatorship and so on but it didn't
mean that gazeta wyborcza the neglected
history in every year you could find
dozens of articles regarding history and
I wouldn't say that this line symbolized
by me how he was dominant in gazeta
wyborcza I think that it would be no
exaggeration saying but we hope gqg will
this article was a symbol of his main
current of publications in gazeta
wyborcza regarding history and now where
you mentioned yet but net debate I just
be strict about fark fact I remember
what it was judge post politer who
started this debate and excellent
articles by andrew katrinak and i would
save it can sted bort i was very
reluctant in the beginning to to to deal
with this issue and then some people who
working does the water told me that it
was a demeaning who wanted to didn't
want to to start this discussion gazeta
wyborcza because he thought that it
would jeopardize for his relations but
it would arise polish anti-semitism
nobody could control this debate because
mass media are out of any control and it
was the news it was the news for the
media that posed in 1941 quite long ago
in fact but still it was the news
murdered jews and and it was impossible
to control this this debate by anyone
and just focused on domestic mentioned
our conversation which we had in
definitely remembers several years ago
and this is true of it i told you that i
really had a problem that because i
wanted to hire historians he and
historians who deal with the time of
occupation second at war and I couldn't
find such people the problem is that
after 89 polish historians felt that the
research regarding Nazi crimes was so
abandoned was so extensive during the
Communist time but but this subject is
not worth any further examining that now
the time has come to deal with research
on the communist dictatorship which is
quite a logical approach because new
sources were released first whether
abandoned Eric I've of Polish Communist
Party which was not explorative in now
by historians only to some extent van
where documents of security apparatus
were released when institute of national
remembrance was created so myself when I
came to very Institute as the head of
research and education branch in two
thousand my idea was what I should
create a team of historians who deal
with history of a communist dictatorship
my impression was with the Second World
War is the time which is in a way less
important that the issue the real issue
is now to start the extensive liver
communist dictatorship but quite
unexpected coincidence was that in the
year 2000 where 2,000 animal gross
published his book neighbors and the
whole discussion regarding secondment
war polish-jewish relations when polish
ukrainian relations started again
another factor was this let's say
offensive new dynamics by the ex police
Erica Steinberg which again brought back
the Second World War as the central
issue to be polish conscience but I
think that it was in a way inevitable
but the great majority of historians
didn't
20th century after 89 they thought that
the time time has come to study not a
second to at war which was started
during the Communist time especially
nasty crimes it was certainly the topic
which was not degli neglected by the
historians during the Communist time so
we simply wanted and I'm think about
myself because i started my academic
career 89 i wanted to deal with time of
a communist because to me it seemed most
important new and then very fresh field
of of research and also just what
Carrasco demsky said that i was unfair
by identifying politics of history with
party politics treating politics of
history as a part of party politics but
in my opinion it was the case i would
say that most of the people who both who
created for example museum of warsaw
uprising most of the people who
published articles about politics of
history and deliberately using this term
political history bay identify not this
is not that i identified them with glo
and Justin they were very close to this
party way where intellectuals who were
involved in many you know initiatives
who were started by this party people
who created museum for surprising they
all became members of parliament from in
the ranks of law and justice they became
ministers in the government or in the
transfer Larry of president kaczynski so
my opinion is that i published in poland
in polish an article will be titled how
politics harmed politics of history and
this is my my idea of it it would be
much better for politics of history
princess was country that of the
minister of education from civic
platform yeah 20 I mean curve ovitch
yeah for instance the other work on the
you know I just wanted to say that it
this division was right at the beginning
of 2005 there was a project of both
parties yeah the all these people
besides besides you you mentioned all
dekosky and aunt Elena jihad suka
uncover who were not covered yeah the
other intellectuals work who came not as
a politician to do this project work
also from Rihanna kita as I said one of
the one of the leading person in this
team was he was proposed to be important
minister in the government in the future
government of andhra kita me myself was
I should be the advisor as a young
Nikita asked me to be his advisors as a
geologist so it doesn't mean you know
this is we have to differentiate the
party politics and what happened then
from the a kind of more general project
and of course is it so that then all the
parties changed a position one radical
existed today probably Civic Platform
eases up and other party that it was
different but it was two years ago but
well you are right but you are right
with respect to the situation before
2005 election there were many
intellectuals who were somehow
cooperating both with en lo quita and
joseph kosinski butter my opinion after
were 92 2005 election many of those
people who took part in inventing this
notion of politics of history became
deeply involved in the law and justice
not only politics in the narrow term but
in many you know initiatives which was
an all closed or initiated by close to
the party or initiative by the partying
you can be a follower of a party not
only have been
Easter but also publishing articles in
the press which you did you know I read
many your your articles and I think that
you would agree with me but you were
much closer to blow and Justice Party in
your analysis defending this party then
to any other party so it's not the
question only of holding some political
posts but also of defending a policy by
by one party the problem is that I would
sympathize with many ideas which were
formulated during these discussions in
2003-2004 that history should be somehow
appreciated Morvant it was in the 90s
but I didn't like political
instrumentalization of this debate and
simply too radical statements now down
playing many important initiatives which
happened before 2004 before two thousand
five I simply cannot accept the argument
but before Law and Justice came to power
history was neglect neglect neglect as
the head of research and education
branching the institute of national
remembrance as early as in let's say
2002 I supervised every year 30 new
exhibitions organized by 11 local
branches of institute of national
remembers most of these exhibitions
visited several towns small towns so it
was a real turning point for me and
saying that the history was neglected by
public institutions in Poland before Law
and Justice came to power is simply you
no sympathy k is simplification we
simply
so well as I said in my opinion politics
harm politics of history it would be
much better if much bigger distance was
kept between what we call politics of
history and party politics and one of
our very concrete question regarding
opinion polls I know opinion polls with
respect to the station in opening of the
thighs of a secret communist police and
the great majority of respondents were
in favor of opening the files in favor
of frustration and one important factor
was with the anger with people the more
in favor of a where of opening the files
thank you would anybody else like to
comment I would write to add some code
comments I agree with I think that
historical circles Hall and the
difference is strongly divided when we
are talking about the politics of of
history I think there are of course
affirmative approach like under a no
Nova and a lot of scope skeptical like
matching color less
the second remarks has semantic
character I don't know what what the
apology really means but I would like to
come for the brochure popularizing the
idea of opening of Museum of Polish
history and we we can read there in the
museum activities the emphasis should
lie on what was unique specific and
fascinating in Polish history poland the
country with one of the longest
republican and parliamentary traditions
in europe the country of citizens
freedom which read a unique liver of the
real religious tolerance in modern
history the country of unique culture
and custom in my opinion is a good
example of apologetic approach to pol
polish congestion so its of course
difficult to make this distinctive
distinctions and
the problem politics of history is the
party politics or not in my opinion the
most of the prominent politicians
connected with law and justice present
this concept as a real part of their
political / problem so they somehow you
user pink this I idea of all politics of
of history and it influenced at the ed
attitude of circle of his historians in
E in Poland it is a result of this egg
activity and one more question connected
with mr. Custer demski commands about
the about the lack of Polish history
ography in in Western historical cell
science the problem cause it was
responsible for the black leg legend of
of Poland in western school
historiography and this this lack of
Polish
synthesis monographs our articles and
and so on and I think I think that first
of all with his historians are
responsible for for it and it's it's
astonished that that that we can we can
say only 11 name of of no Norman Dale
Davis as a representative of Polish
historiography in in West not nowadays
and I appreciated his his books were
very much but it's not enough I think
thank you i would like to refer to the
words of Professor Craster demski he
record us about the problem of the
weakness of Polish historiography and in
them the weak weak presence of Polish
historiography abroad this is the very
important problem we have many books
about not only about German German
German resistance German opposition to
Hitler and very little about polish home
army about Polish underground movement
but also about for example Polish
foreign policy of the interwar period
about the activities of polish or polish
diplomacy in this time in the
international arena and this is the
question
which is very important today for for us
and the situation should be changed but
how to change it it is another problem
for another conference thank you thank
you gentlemen we're at the end of this
period and we promised to leave some
time at the end of our day for to return
to things that we were talking about
last night and this morning so if
anybody would like to approach something
that they didn't have a chance to finish
I invite you and please just mention to
whom you direct your your question or
your comment actually I I I don't want
to address it to anybody in particular
it's about the historic policy and lack
of that in Poland and the reasons I I
think that one of the reason is that
majority of influential so-called
intellectuals or public opinion makers
in early 90s in Poland many people of
this circle was simply afraid of history
I mean they were afraid personally about
history they were afraid about history
because they were many of them once
again they were dissidents what doesn't
mean dissident dissident means not
somebody who fought the communion
because many people thought communism
some of them they were dissidents
dissidence from somewhere from the
Communist structures or Communist Party
and those people they were somehow skirt
about revealing the history of the
Communist years in Poland because it
would touch them
us directly many times and this was one
reason that they were somehow if not
against the research of the recent
history in Poland they were not in favor
they would not promote it the other
reason was that they were taught grew up
in the opposition being children in the
opposition to the pre-war Poland are in
the opposition to the Second Republic or
it wasn't their own experience because
they were too young but it was for sure
the experience of many fathers of them
and father day father's they I mean if
their fathers experience was a bad
experience because of many different
reasons but once again many of them
really didn't like Poland between the
wars and the discussion about content I
mean recent history a modern history of
Poland would touch this point once again
and they didn't want it so those reasons
combined they make the result
anybody else
I have a young specific question
director 21 all members of the panel
what is the best book to read and to
inform yourself in any western language
including publish of course Western
European language or published about
property transfers that is the transfers
of Polish state property during the
period of shock therapy in the early
1990s how former top-level civil
servants of the Polish People's Republic
became overnight capitals bought and
sold this property how they might form
the social basis of the new elite in
Poland what would you read to inform
yourself about the beneficiaries of
shock therapy
a very site owner there is a book
published died and Roberto Pete
regarding the role played by former
security functionaries but not not not
only in the economic processes but this
is a larger proud to the whole
transformation a transformation
post-college title is push this button
exclusion zipper tajuk's zy
anybody else have a comment or a
question well then let me say some
concluding remarks about the last two
days the job of our small Center the
east central european center at columbia
is to explore a variety of issues that
are of interest both the students into
faculty things that are both historical
and contemporary and every semester we
try to do something different somebody
asked me earlier or yesterday why we
picked dealing with the past the choice
of which historical model you wish to
promote analyst tration and I guess the
answer is because it was there now what
we thought of it we figured that it was
going to have much more of an impact
than it's having today simply because of
the political atmosphere in Poland and
we also thought that this would be a
good time to explore and compare what is
going on in countries in the region and
we learned a lot one of the things that
comes out of a conference like this even
though i don't see our check colleague
in the room is the information on the
opening of the check archives which is a
very recent development and which may
have an impact on how those people the
authorities in countries around the
czech republic will now begin to view
how they should pursue access policies
in their respective countries and as we
listened over the last couple of days we
all know that there's no one simple
answer for for everyone and that
countries are going at different speeds
so we may very well expect to see under
this new government in Poland some
changes in access to the archives of the
Institute for national remembrance and
perhaps even to other archives that are
available at this stage only two
researchers in Poland but maybe under a
slightly different policy within the
neck
few years and I think that that's a very
good thing if there's one thing that
came through particularly from this
discussion today it's that the things
that we're talking about are not a new
development people have been questioning
what happened in the past and each
generation has come to a different
conclusion about each country's history
as cheese puffs Castle Adamski in his
remarks just a few minutes ago said
something about polls believing or a
group of polls believing that they have
been defeated overtime they're beginning
to sound like Hungarians if you ask a
Hungarian there will be the first to
tell you that they've never won a battle
in their long history which is not true
of course it does express a certain
pessimism about the inevitability of
history and how we always seem to find
ourselves back in the same spot that's
what conferences like this I think are
good for to reassess what current
perspectives are on some of these issues
and of course we could only scratch the
surface I don't believe that there's
anybody else writing in Poland at least
that I know of on a topic that madacorp
not addressed today which is how these
issues affect international relations
and it was a useful exercise to remember
that people didn't start doing this when
the catching ski twins took over they
have been doing this the whole time so
these are useful exercises for people
who are in the business of addressing
students and have to find new ways to
explain what's going on today based on
information that they may have forgotten
or that they're just learning from their
colleagues and it was very nice to have
somebody talk about what's going on in
Romania and a decent discussion about
both historical politics in Germany and
also illustration in Germany and of
course we could have covered many more
countries in Europe and also placed the
East Central European region into a
larger context but that would have taken
of course more time and that's something
that we really didn't have the
possibility to do so I want to thank all
of our colleagues who came for
from canada who came from prague who
came from different cities in poland who
came from such far away places as North
Carolina am I missing anybody we have
Turkish colleagues in the room who are
also find what we're talking about quite
interesting we intend to continue with
meetings like this probably the next one
won't have such a historical dimension
it will be more contemporary but we are
able to do this at the central european
center because we have friends it's
always good to have friends and it's
always good to have friends who have
money we're lucky that we have the
prostitution foundation here in new york
city and the senate of the republic of
poland which acts through the semper
Polonia foundation in warsaw to bolster
our meager resources and to allow not
purely polish debates but poland in the
context of a larger larger setting and i
would like to hope that our colleagues
in other countries would have the good
fortune also to find a partner
institution in the united states that
would like to do things with them just
as we do i think that this is something
this is what brought me to colombia
three decades ago and there are other
people who find this kind of
intellectual exercise quite fulfilling
so on their behalf i'd like to thank you
i also want to let you know that
hopefully within a few weeks these
deliberations will be online and in the
interim you will probably also find some
mention of it in the local press here in
New York at least in the Polish language
press so thank you very much and until
next time
you